Donald Trump's travel ban is going into
effect the summer federal courts had
previously put two different versions of
the ban on hold to resolve questions
about its constitutionality and on June
26th the Supreme Court ruled that the
ban can take effect with some
limitations before the High Court
reviews it in the fall the band stops
all tourists from six majority Muslim
countries from entering the US for at
least 90 days and all refugees for at
least 120 days unless they already have
a visa or have a bona fide relationship
with a person or organization in America
Trump's bans could almost be over by the
time the court hears the case Trump
called the Supreme Court's decision a
clear victory for our national security
and he did title into shoes the
protection of the nation from foreign
terrorists and into the unite after the
first ban was put on hold by a judge in
Washington and the Ninth Circuit Court
of Appeals Trump signed what was in his
words a quote watered down version with
the same title but there is absolutely
no evidence for such a security benefit
Americans were more likely to be killed
by their own clothes than by an
immigrant terrorist and nobody in the US
has been killed in a terrorist attack by
immigrants from these particular six
nations in the last 40 years
but while the temporary bans have gotten
all the headlines the order has sent the
u.s. down a path of a fundamental shift
in American refugee policy reviewing all
admitting procedures and announcing that
in the future refugees will only be
admitted from countries that ensure the
security and welfare of the United
States
this is the opposite of how the US has
defined refugees in the past people
fleeing persecution and violence that
their own governments cannot or will not
protect them from and this comes at a
time when the world faces its biggest
refugee crisis since World War two when
one in 122 people are displaced so if
you're worried about us terrorist
attacks like 9/11 San Bernardino or the
Orlando pulse shooting this order would
have prevented none of them but if you
happen to be afraid of Muslims this ban
might sound pretty good it falls in line
with Trump's anti-muslim statements the
most famous of which he said during the
campaign Donald J Trump is calling for a
total and complete shutdown of Muslims
entering the United States the attitude
that people fleeing terror war and
famine are dangerous
that attitude resulted in the infamous
decision in June 1939 to turn away in
the st. Louis a ship carrying 937 Jewish
refugees fleeing another hostile
government Hitler's first they were
turned away in Cuba then they approached
Florida but the US Coast Guard
patrolling the waters kept them away too
they eventually disembarked in Belgium
the Netherlands and France hundreds died
in the Holocaust since then the US
government has been the world's leader
in resettling refugees the State
Department website still brags about it
claiming three million refugees
resettled around all 50 states since
1975 the Statue of Liberty bares these
goals to a plaque on the pedestal reads
give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
the wretched refuse of your teeming
Shore send these the homeless
tempest-tossed to me I lift my lamp
beside the Golden Door America hasn't
always lived up to these lofty goals but
since World War two we've lived in an
era where the diversity of who gets to
come to America has gone up and up
regardless of where you come from
the Trump administration has been trying
to end this era since January after
multiple defeats it's won its first
battle and seeing through this vision
lawyers and protesters are sure to try
to preserve it around the country in
this fall in the Supreme Court
[Music]
you